[Music]
my name is Adam Pomerance niño and
Murray's bagels and Leos bagels in New
York City bagels originated in Portland
and when they were brought to the United
States 100 120 years ago the turn of the
century
Eastern European Jews hate them all the
time it was it was one of these ethnic
foods that over the years became really
mainstream so growing up in Brooklyn and
Staten Island my Irish friends my
Italian friends just you name it
everyone ate bagels so I think everyone
treats New York Jewish soul food as just
real American eats
so both Leo's bagels and Murray's bagels
we do just a real traditional method the
way things were done 100 years ago five
basic ingredients high gluten flour salt
yeast barley malt that's kind of a
unique ingredient in New York bagel it's
a lot of people just use sugar and of
course we use New York City tap water
which I do feel makes a difference of
course we hand roll the bagels after we
roll the bagels they're proofed which is
just the yeast is activating and the
bales are rising after proofing we put
them in the walk-in refrigerator for at
least a day and this is where the bagel
develops its crust
we then kettle the bagels we throw them
in boiling water for about 15 maybe 30
seconds but it's here that the
gelatinization of the starch takes place
and it's an important process because
what's happening is the surface of the
bagel is getting cooked and that's where
the crust and that shine is coming from
and then we scoop the bagels out of the
kettle put them on the burlap covered
boards and it's here that the toppings
are placed on both sides of the bagels
this is the time when we put the bagels
into the oven and a minute or two later
we flip them we'll wait about 10 15
minutes in the oven just for the bagels
to get that perfect kind of golden shine
and that's it
every Thursday night growing up my
father who had a ladies clothing store
in the Lower East Side of Manhattan
would always bring home bagels bialys
and smoked fish yes our soul food so if
we knew what a true New York bagel
should taste like so I was working in
finance back about 25 years ago and
living in Greenwich Village just a few
blocks from this shop and I realized
that the one thing that a New York Jew
really needed in this area was a good
bagel shop there are great bagel shops
and Queens and Brooklyn and Manhattan
but really I don't think you can get a
great bagel outside of New York City
[Music]